foreign
five things I do not need as a
minimalist I'm saying I don't need these
things earlier TK you were talking about
toasters yeah I don't use a toaster I
haven't used a toaster in so many years
although my wife owns one I couldn't
even tell you I mean we hide it away we
don't put it on the counter but if she
makes sourdough bread so she does use it
my wife's a minimalist I'm a minimalist
we own different things I don't ever
need a toaster I don't ever want a
toaster they're so crummy
oh don't tweet that podcast John and
right next to where my toaster isn't is
where my microwave isn't that's the next
object that I don't own as a minimalist
I've realized that when I would live
places and it came with a microwave I
would use it maybe once a year I
remember once I moved into a home in
Missoula and I didn't realize for over a
year that we had a microwave a microwave
yeah remember that really wait we have a
microwave
Colin was using it one day right wait a
minute where did you get that and it's
so funny like as soon as you develop
that pattern then you might start using
the thing but the pattern I developed
was I don't need to use this thing I can
do things more slowly and so I get by
without a microwave here's another thing
this reminds me of the fight club
remember the the scene where the
narrator is talking to Tyler Durden on
the airplane and and Tyler Durden says
what's a duvet cover he's like why do
you know what a duvet cover is right
he's like it's just a blanket and yet we
have duvet covers right I haven't owned
a duvet cover in years the reason I
don't because I hate the way that they
are shaped on the bed and so I simply
don't have a duvet cover I don't even
know what that is it's a blanket cover
it's a pillow case for your blanket
essentially or for your comforter oh
okay
right exactly okay that's my response as
well do they criticize you for this oh
my stars I'm done I will say it's much
easier I don't own a duvet cover but
it's much easier to clean it rather than
taking the whole bulky blanket and
shoving it in there yeah we I mean I
wash my comforter when I need to wash it
and uh that's worked out really fine for
me oh you know what's okay so I actually
do use a duvet cover so we had a we had
a um a fluffy
cover whatever fluffy duvet I guess and
uh then Mariah put something on it like
so that way it we we didn't get the
actual cover dirty the comforter the
comforter thank you and long story short
uh the comforter was way too hot for me
so I took the comforter out and now I
use only the duvet cover wow amazing
mainly because I didn't want to buy
another blanket I'm like ah this this
thing will actually probably work and it
does and that's that's what I use now
just when I was I was getting ready to
take away your minimalist certificate
now I have to give it back to him I've
renewed your license Ryan thanks guys
thanks God thanks God thanks God by the
way you brought up Brad Pitt or fight
club
um you're you're on your way to becoming
Brad Pitt's character in The Big Short
like you're already 75 there yeah
explain why
well I mean he's he's out in the
Boondocks right like just deliberately
just away uh no Wi-Fi right no TV no TV
when the guys who are like really
ambitious and talented and financially
illiterate come to him for tips on how
to make money he's kind of like you know
what I'm gonna help you guys but I I
promise you it's not gonna make you as
happy
his like heart is too generous so he has
to help but he's kind of like annoyed
then these guys they could have more
having more money is going to help them
you're totally becoming you know what I
respect about Josh is once Josh latches
onto something he will like take it as
far as he can and I really admire that
about Josh and uh I'm looking forward to
seeing what you give up next well the
next two things
I was thinking about chewing chewing
seems so
I'm just gonna do some steak smoothies
from now on I'm just gonna slurp no
chewing I'm gonna that's true for me
like a little baby bird
all right two other things I uh I don't
have a TV at home and I don't have a
Wi-Fi router because I don't have
internet at home now those are things
that might change because I know Bex is
like I'm getting tired of not having
Internet at home and so the solution I
talked about in a lot of people use
things is if you want I had someone
asked this question the other day hey I
want to go without internet at home but
my partner really wants it what do you
do well you can ask them to hide the
Wi-Fi router password and therefore they
have the password you don't you
functionally don't have internet the
other person in the house does crisis
averted same thing with TV like I'm not
against TV I don't think it's wrong or
evil I simply don't have a TV I haven't
had one for a long time I haven't owned
one in a very very long time last
apartment I lived in had one
last thing for me a wristwatch I love
watches I just hate them on my wrist
every time Jordan posts something about
a watch I'm like that's a really
beautiful like
a mechanical like really awesome piece
of Machinery I hate things touching my
wrist though anyway I love wrist watches
oh except for your hand Jordan
and I are big wristwatch fans yeah and
here's the thing I appreciate Jordan's
obsession with wrist watches because
what you were talking about earlier
let's watch too man thank you brother I
appreciate it it really is I mean that
from the bottom of my heart and when I
dive deep into something I tend to get
obsessed about something that's what I
really appreciate about Jordan I'm not
obsessed about watches in a way so it
used to be that I would buy expensive
watches why because to look who I am
that's right look at my tag here yeah am
I saying that right I think so tag
Howard
so this is my one
um I had two because Jordan gave me a
gift welcoming welcoming me here really
beautiful watch but I was showing it to
my dad and telling him the story about
it and he really loved it and I was like
you want it pop he was like yeah so I
gave it yeah that's great so I'm back
down to one that's nice man here's a
bonus one for you sunglasses I no longer
wear sunglasses he loves glaucoma am I
saying that right glaucoma no no it's
glaucoma I'm kidding you can watch the
video that we did about it on YouTube
how sunglasses are now obsolete you can
check that out I've never been into one
but you were obviously into them why'd
you get rid of it because I realized
that it messed up my circadian rhythm
which was harming my sleep personally
individual results May Vary did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalist or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free